ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Hi, everyone.
We're back here, and
this is Francois.
And we're talking today
about the Developer
Mode in Chrome and Chrome OS.
Actually, there are
different things.
So let's try to cover this and
straighten a few things out,
if needed.
So first of all, what
are we not talking about?
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: That's
an open topic, actually.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: So we
mentioned the developer channel
in Chrome OS in a
previous episode.
This is not--
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: Nope.
ALEXIS
MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: --what
we're talking about today, OK.
This is not Chrome
DevTools, either.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: Either, no.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Developer tools.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT:
Completely different thing.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: If
you want to debug your web app,
go through the DOM, and look at
your CSS and network traffic,
all that.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: Not that.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Nope, not that either, OK.
It's more about power users,
and developers specifically.
So first thing,
Chrome the browser.
There's a Developer Mode in
every Chrome installation
that there is on every OS.
What does that help you do?
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: And that's
very confusing, actually.
But if you go to
the extension page,
like the internal extension
page, chrome://extensions,
you can see a checkbox.
And this Developer Mode checkbox
lets you, as an extension
developer, debug and load
some unpacked extension.
That's pretty useful.
You can also update
your extensions.
Usually Chrome just tries
for two or three hours
to pull some Web
Store data, just
to see if there is an update.
And you can just click on
this button and trigger it.
So that's not what
we're talking, either.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
OK, but it's worth knowing it
exists, probably, if you
are developing today--
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT:
You know that.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Applications or extensions.
You know it exists,
because that's the only way
to install an app
which is developed,
and that sits and lives locally.
And if you want to
share this with others
and have them try it
out, they probably
need to have that
mode enabled, as well.
So let's talk about
the Developer Mode
in Chrome OS on Chrome devices.
So one thing you
can do is actually--
first of all, for those
that are not aware,
there is a command line
interface to Chrome OS.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT:
Definitely yes.
If you just press Control Alt
T on a brand new Chrome device,
you stumble upon a page which
is like the Chrome developer
shell.
We've not many options
like, top, ping, SSH,
some basic commands that
you may need at some point.
But that's pretty much it.
ALEXIS
MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Right.
So you're definitely-- you
don't have root privileges.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: No.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
But you do have SSH.
So this is built on Linux.
So there are a
number of features
that are made available through
that command line interface.
Now we can actually
root the machine,
or gain root access
to that machine.
And is that something
important for people
to be able to do that?
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: Definitely.
The Chromium team
believes in the fact
that every Chrome
device on Earth
should be able to own
his or her own machine.
So that means installing
another distribution, maybe.
Or just becoming
[INAUDIBLE], basically.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
OK, so just
taking ownership of the hardware
independently of the software.
So if you want to install
something completely different,
you're able to do that.
OK.
So tell me, what does it
take to actually enable that?
Walk us through the steps here.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: OK.
You want to know
maybe before, why
you want to enable
the Developer Mode.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Sure.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: Sure.
So first of all,
like I said, you
can install a
Chromium-based distribution.
So let's say you compiled
your own Chromium OS.
You can install it.
That's pretty cool.
You can install another
Linux distribution.
You can also boot
from a USB key or SD
card, where you
install another OS.
What can you do also?
My favorite thing is
actually to install Crouton.
So Crouton is like a
Chroot environment,
which lets you run, side by
side, Ubuntu or another Linux
distribution next to Chrome OS.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
And when you say side by side,
it's one kernel running
two distributions.
So you get all of Chrome
OS, as you know, and--
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: Yeah.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Like it and love it.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: It's so
easy to switch between the two.
ALEXIS
MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Right,
and what does it take to switch?
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: Control Alt
and you can use the F keys.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
OK, great.
So what do you lose
in the process?
You must be losing something.
First of all, updates,
and Developer Mode
here is not the
developer channel.
These are two
unrelated concepts.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: Yep.
You can be on stable,
on beta, on dev channels
and still get your
updates, even though you
have activated the
developer mode.
I'm always in developer mode,
and I always got the update.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
OK, so updates keep coming in,
whatever channel you have, when
you are in the Developer Mode
and when you've
rooted your machines.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: But you're
losing one thing, yes--
the verified boot.
And that's really important.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
So verified boot
is clearly one of the
important features of Chrome OS
or Chromebooks.
Tell us, for those who
don't know what it is.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: So, in short,
when you have a Chromebook,
you can only run Chrome OS.
And you can't trick
your machine to try
to load another
distribution or another OS.
It's just Chrome OS.
ALEXIS
MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Right.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: And
that's the verified boot.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
And it's
a security feature, really.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: Of course.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
OK, so can I disable that?
I want to go back to what I
consider a safer environment.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: So let me
show you how to enter it first.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Oh yeah, please.
Yes, we didn't cover that.
Go.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: So it's
pretty easy, actually.
So there is a page
on Chrome that
explains for each device
which are the steps.
But the most common step
are the virtualized one.
So you just press Escape, the
refresh button, and the power.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
OK, power button.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: So it reboots
the button, your Chromebook.
And then you just press Control
D, D like Developer, and Enter.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: OK.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: And then
for five to 10 minutes,
depending on your device,
it will erase everything
on your machine.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: OK.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: And boom,
you are in Developer Mode.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
So from there on, when
I start the Chromebook,
it will tell you
you're about to start this in
Developer Mode, are you sure?
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: No,
there is no are you sure.
But there is basically
a white screen
where you have to
wait for 30 seconds.
And then you've got these
annoying [MIMICS SOUND].
So you have to-- if you press
Control D, you just keep that,
and then you go through
the usual experience.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
And then you are rooted,
and then you can do
anything you want.
And you do have root privileges.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: Exactly.
So, like before you
just do Control Alt
T to open the developer shell.
And now I've got a
new command shell.
And now I can just do sudo su.
Boom.
I'm root.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: OK.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: I can
do pretty much what I want.
ALEXIS
MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Great.
So about--
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: And how do
you leave this Developer Mode?
Actually, you just need
to read the instructions
at the beginning.
It tells you just press space.
Space, Enter, and
now you are gone.
And you don't need to wait.
Just in 10 seconds, you
just left Developer Mode.
ALEXIS
MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Great.
So hopefully that's
clear for you.
This was about the
Developer Modes.
There are different ones.
I think we focused
mostly on Chrome OS,
but hopefully we talked
about the other things
that are named after developers.
We'll be seeing you in
another episode real soon.
Thank you, Francois.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT:
Hopefully, yes.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Cheers.